un soplo de aire fresco para italia con
el índice de contagio con tendencia a la
baja el ministerio de sanidad ha
indicado que todo el país pasaría a ser
amarillo el lunes según su sistema de
restricciones diferenciador por colores
en función de la gravedad de la
situación sanitaria esa relajación
permite la reapertura diurna de pares y
restaurantes y una mayor libertad para
viajar dentro de la región sin embargo
sigue vigente el toque de queda nocturno
en todo el país y cuatro regiones
seguirán siendo naranjas a la espera de
una mejor evolución del virus el momento
es un momento muy delicado para el país
tenemos que afrontarlo con la máxima
responsabilidad para dar las respuestas
urgentes que los ciudadanos están
esperando un abandono en reacción la
rama europea de la organización mundial
de la salud advirtió al jueves que era
demasiado pronto para relajarse debido a
una presencia todavía muy alta del virus
francia por su parte no se relaja desde
este domingo cerró sus fronteras a todos
los viajes que no sean imprescindibles
desde hacía países de fuera de la unión
europea además las personas que lleguen
desde el interior del bloque tendrán que
presentar ante este cierre negativo el
presidente manuel makoun defendió su
decisión de abstenerse de un tercer
cierre confío en nosotros estas horas
que estamos viviendo son cruciales
hagamos todo lo posible para frenar
juntos la epidemia por su parte ante el
crecimiento exponencial de los contagios
portugal ha anunciado que cerrará las
fronteras terrestres con españa a partir
del domingo durante un periodo de al
menos dos semanas periodo durante el
cual sólo se permitirá la entrada por
motivos laborales o para visitar a
parejas